Hold on hold on hold on
There's not a lot of chance, I will chance my life
I hope I'm on the right thing
And then
They're not messed up
Who's driving this booze?
Come on boys is so messed up
Valor
Am I streaming? I don't see it.
It'll be live for 40 seconds. I can't even see myself.
Oh, there we go. Hey, I can hear myself.
Ah, I totally lost my voice. Testing.
Ah, freaking scary.
Broke my damn voice on that bloody stream.
Didn't that be alert? Did you like that smoke? Did you like it?
Right, from here on out, it's nothing but scuffing memes.
If you're looking for professionals, go elsewhere, buddy.
Go to Shibi's stream. There's no happening here.
I promise you, mate. My voice is so strange right now.
Oh, my goodness. Just the way we were like,
Oh, it's been a bloody while since we've been together.
Fuck me, man. That took me a year to spawn this.
Oh, my God.
I did it, though. Holy shit, we did it.
Feet sniffer. I didn't mean to imply greed.
No, you didn't. I know you didn't. Please don't worry.
Please don't worry. It's fine.
The only reason I say greed is because of the perspective thing.
Oh, fucking mischief, reflins. My fucking God.
What a year it's been. Holy crap.
I know I'm supposed to talk about my debut,
but let's be honest, we're all reflins here.
Oh, fucking mischiefs.
Of course, your names were going to be refling.
Oh, my God.
What do you mean you became a squid vtuber
just so your name may only reflect you in another life?
Oh, come on. Refling.
Come on. If I'm on a reef, get it?
Great barrier. Reef. Reef.
Oh, I'm so excited to play Assassin's Creed Brotherhood with you.
When this stream ends, I'm going to unlist all my streams.
Any reefers on the track? Are reefers cannabis?
I can't say that.
Does reeflings mean something different?
In another life, I had a fan base called Reeflings,
but it was spelled slightly different.
And I made it pronounced the same, but spelled differently.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
If you're not really familiar with me from the past,
don't worry about it.
Okay, don't worry about it.
I'm just strong at cuttles. Let's keep it that way.
Thank you very much.
Okay, am I actually going through my 2.0
or are we just squidding around?
My bottle.
I have my reefing mail.
Skullfish.
Oh, Skullfish is so good.
Oh, that's actually really small.
Okay.
Thank you.
Right, I'll actually go through my slides,
but I'm not really sure if there's much of a point,
because, well,
that's Johnny's 365 from Beast's Suck It.
Moment.
Product or moment.
Right, let me drink my cola.
Let me drink my cola.
Yeah, I was supposed to say 5.3.
Also, someone doubted that Scots is a recognized language.
It is.
So, you know how it sounds like I'm speaking English here all the time?
I'm going to give you a sentence, okay?
I'm going to type it in chat so you can read it.
So, that is a sentence in Scots that I've just typed, okay?
And it says,
Are you coming to my bit tonight?
That means, are you coming to my house tonight?
That's Scots.
He has a bit different.
It's not in the best sense,
but it's what I can think of on the top of my head, but yeah.
Are you coming to my bit tonight?
It means, are you coming to my house?
And I purposely don't really speak with a lot of slang
or mumble the way I naturally do,
because I'm quite naturally monotone and mumbley,
because the problem is,
you guys don't understand me because I'm Scots.
But if you are British or you're familiar with the Scottish accent,
then I probably actually don't sound from Scots indeed,
but it is what it is.
And also, I've been very, like,
when you're on the internet, you're very Americanised
with what you consume.
Does it take all your efforts to pronounce every syllable
and not speak Scots?
No, my mother dearest,
she actually taught me,
she discouraged me from speaking in slang,
so I doesn't always naturally come out,
but here's what it is.
Here's how it was at the beginning.
I said, fucking cheers to that mate, cheers to that.
But yeah, technically, legally, on paper,
because I was born in Scotland,
I could speak two languages, thank you.
I don't need any help from Joe Lingo, let's go.
But yeah, so I'm a siren that can't sing.
Gee willikers, I wonder why.
I just don't have a voice.
I'm also tone deaf, by the way,
so I hope you're ready for drunk karaoke streams.
That stuff's gonna be intense.
Let's see where these slides are.
So both of your parents are Scots, eh?
Yeah, the band-aids hold up, still top tier.
Yep, very top tier.
Mongolian throat singing.
The reason I don't like Mongolian throat singing
is because cats don't like Mongolian throat singing,
because of the vibration.
It's an unpleasant sound.
I have learned many traits of cats, so I don't like it.
Drunk karaoke.
Shibi's doing drunk ASMR this week.
If that's your...
Is that your thing?
To say, is that your thing?
And Scots, you go, is that your thing?
Is that I?
Is that your thing?
Oh, it is him and I.
And...
There you go.
Yeah, I did some basic stuff.
Oh, my lore's being retconned, by the way.
Thanks to you guys.
Apparently, my weaknesses are mirrors,
which I really fucking like.
I'm definitely gonna do something with that,
because I think it's such a cool thing.
I should have done it like a fucking character reference,
like strengths, weaknesses,
because that would have been so much cooler to do the havel.
I actually have started reading this year.
I had a really rough year last year.
Gee, I wonder.
And I started...
I picked up reading.
I have never read in my life.
And...
Turns out, I really like the stopian novels.
Like George Orwell was so good.
Like Animal Farm in 1984.
I absolutely love 1984.
Fahrenheit was good.
I've read the classics.
I'm not read that much, but...
I see you're readin' right?
Yeah.
The Women in the Dunes, as well,
is like the perfect, like, book,
because it, like, encapsulates, like, human nature.
And...
I just love, like, depressing books.
I love being depressed at the end and being like,
no, humanity didn't prevail.
No, not humanity, what's the word?
Human nature didn't prevail against the odds.
I've got the Hobbit.
I've not read it yet, but I have the physical copy of the Hobbit.
And I'm so excited.
Um...
Yeah, I'm not much of a...
The girls, by far, are more weebs than me.
I am, by far, the gamer.
Like, I played the most games.
Doesn't mean I'm good before anyone fucking complains.
Every time you mention you play games,
what do you mean you're not top 500 in this game?
You suck, like, no, I play video games.
Fucking relax, I bet you're shit at them, too.
Like, my god, can you hear yourself?
You're actually, like, so fucking negative.
Anyway, I'll help you get more positive.
Actually, the reason why you're negative
is because you're KD's negative,
because you're scrubbing the game.
That's why you just project.
Anyway, that's just me.
Uh, music, I'm really generic with music.
I don't listen to music much, okay?
Uh, movies, Lord of the Rings, we're at hell, yeah?
Uh, if you don't know, uh, I have plans for on Christmas
and Boxing Day, uh, to watch Lord of the Rings
and The Hobbit, Phil Marathon, absolutely adore it.
Uh, that would be public stream,
no gate keeping, no membership, none of that jazz.
Oh, special thank you to everyone who watched the debut.
I already meet the requirements for monetization on YouTube.
The problem is the stats don't update for, like, 48 hours.
So I can technically, like, I already meet the requirements.
I just need to submit myself to YouTube.
And then I can do my monetization stream!
And I'm so excited, because my idea is so cursed.
But I just want to say, for anyone who's watching me right now,
if you don't like VTubers doing webcam streams,
showing their hands or their feet,
I'm not a VTuber for you, however FILR Girls, absolutely.
Check them out in the description.
You can hit subscribe!
Uhm...
But, yes, absolutely no hints to what my monetization stream's going to be.
Uhuhuhuh!
Mmmhmm?
Mmmhmmmmmm!
You ain't ready, I literally need to go to a nail parlor.
I've been growing my nails for three weeks
for the monetization stream.
of having long nails. I hate it, I hate it, but I'm doing it for you.
Animes, uh, um, Kaki-Guri, still one of my top. Kaki-Guri, Kaga-Guri, Kaga-Guri, still
one of my top. It's probably one of my top. I don't, I can't think of anything that.
Actually, fun fact, do you want to know the very first anime I got tricked into watching?
Fucking Boku no Pico, or whatever the frickin' Dilla, Piccadilla sauce, whatever the frickin' thing is.
That is the first exposure to anime I ever had, and I was mortified. Mortified!
I had no concept, a little innocent me, tick-tackin' on the keyboard.
Ooh, this anime's being recommended! I should watch it!
And then, so I was really dumb, do you know how it has a warning at the start?
I didn't know what that word meant, like, and I watched it.
I was like, where is this ice cube going?
And, like, and actually, I want to use my notice.
My first ever exposure to, uh, uh, like an anime that wasn't Boku no Pico, it related, was a brother in...
Oh my god, ooh! Sorry, I thought there was a spider on me, holy crap.
It wasn't. It was my cover.
My first anime exposure, it was either...
It must have been an anime based on a manga that got popular, because that's how most anime's turned out, Ida.
It was a brother and sister. Hold on! Hold on!
Hold the frickin' phone for y'all circle men.
It was brother and sister, and then it was...
The sister is a flesh eater, and the guy's like, oh, it's fine.
And he has, like, regenerative powers or something?
I'm sure one of you guys know what it is.
It was either a manga I read or a thingy, but she had to, like, eat him for some reason,
and she was like, oh, I'm so sorry for eating you, hum hum hum hum hum.
And I was like, oh!
Yeah, that was the first of her anime exposure that, like, I got into, and I was like, oh, this shit's crazy.
And then I discovered what Pururin is.
Many a day on Pururin.
And then they shut down the website, Rippin' Piss.
You will be missed, actually. Sorry, my voice is absolutely short.
I promise this isn't my default voice, it's because I'm so excited to talk to you.
I've broken my voice already.
I came back.
Shut up, Pururin did not come. Hold on.
Hold on, we're doing research like Pururin.
Pururin.
Oh my god, no! I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
I have, I may have a bikini toggle.
I may have a bikini toggle for water ASMR streams.
I am so sorry.
I will unbind the keys for an X-treme.
I will take your word chat that Pururin is back.
I apologize for that.
My deepest condolence.
Okay, no.
Okay, I don't even know what to say to that.
Right, move it on, swiftly.
And, swiftly, swiftly.
We'll take another drink of me, Nikola.
I don't even know what key did that.
Was it you, maybe?
Literally, I look over at my screen and I'm like, where's my Yucata?
Where did it go? Why is it through the window?
Anyway, next, next thing.
Yes, Childhood Games!
Oh my god, I am so happy that Xbox Game Pass is a thing.
I need to create an account, I don't know what to call it yet.
I want to make it something like Mimi or Funny.
But yeah, anyway, I'm an Xbox kid
and if you were able to catch the group stream,
it's actually true that I had to present games to my dad to buy for me.
Or he would just buy it for me because he was like,
oh, that's good for response-o.
Inherit your dad's account.
So, these are the majority of the games that I remember.
I'm going to do tons of Xbox games.
I'm an Xbox kid.
I never had a PlayStation at all.
So I didn't have access.
I had a PlayStation.
My dad got a PlayStation 1.
I didn't know how to read, like, no.
So I'm just trying to think, like, the timeline.
A lot of these games I've played, I didn't even have the ability to read yet.
Like, I used to watch my dad play the games because I was so small.
But yeah, basically.
Sonic Generations.
Is Sonic Generations the one that was made after Sonic Heroes?
I've not played BioShock 2.
No, I played BioShock 1.
Well, you had bees.
Bees?
My sweet little bumblebee.
I know what you want from me.
Hypnosis-themed feature where I really like hypnosis.
I've never done it before, but I'm going to participate in it and try and get it for you.
I never played Sonic Generations then.
No, I played Sonic Heroes and then there was a bit of a skip.
I played Sonic Unleashed where he's like that werewolf.
But I got stuck in the game because I was, like, too young.
Not very smart. I'm not a very smart gamer, okay?
Which is why I am perfectly happy with
hand-holding through games.
Some streamers really don't like backseat gaming.
For me, absolutely do not mind it.
I'm daft, okay?
I'm completely daft.
I have no clue what's going on.
Would we be hypnotised to vote for you as president?
Oh my god.
But yeah, so definitely going to replay a lot of Xbox games
as my childhood dream was that 100k thingy.
I only had the opportunity to play Fable 3.
Wait, let me see what's behind me.
Hold on. What's behind me?
Oh, Viva Pinata, Trials Evolution.
Right now my game of choice is The Binding of Isaac.
It's an absolutely fantastic game.
It becomes multiplayer in November.
Multiplayer in November.
Just a warning for anyone who is out there
binding their Isaac.
November games, multiplayer games
are most likely going to be Isaac.
I apologise. I too.
The best Halo game in your opinion.
I'm biased and can say combat evolved
because my dad used to play it over and over
and I used to hide behind the couch.
I was so scared from the grunty oneies.
They were so scary.
You actually finished Meat Boy.
Damn it, like I finished Meat Boy.
No, I played it. These games don't necessarily mean
I'm finished them, but yeah.
Hamster's Lifestream win.
Yeah, you want to play a hamster game together.
Yeah.
Is combat evolved the first one?
Yeah, sorry. Halo combat evolved is the first one.
You're like Crash Land and everyone dies, but you...
It's just scary.
They're straight up.
What in the strip club, straight up binding it
and by it, let's just say my Isaac.
Oh my god, my favourite meme right now
is like, replace the A with a F
and then it says fart, relax, snowflake.
It's called Dark Humour. It's my favourite meme right now.
I've also got those old games
from the Xbox original days.
Definitely going to give them a shot again.
AC actually mentioned that she played
American McGee's Alice
and I've played Alice in Madness Returns
and I thought she was going to say
she played American McGee's Alice, but...
Yeah.
God of War
enjoyed that, that was good.
I need to play Shadow of Mordor properly.
I actually want to play the Golem game
that got absolutely review bombed.
Everyone hated it, but I feel like I'm like
Tismo enough because it's Lord of the Rings
Lord of the Rings related
to play it and the entire time
I want to do Golem's voice
and I'm like, thank you.
I like absolutely wrecked my voice
to like roleplay as Golem.
I mean, you know, we started again.
I'd love to do that.
My face when I didn't realise Madness Returns
in the sequel.
Oh, mercy, I'm about to ruin your day.
There was a third instalment called
Alice Asylum and EA rejected it.
The game has been fully conceptualised,
EA rejected it and now it's gathering dust.
So that's just to ruin your day.
There was to be a third instalment
of Alice in Wonderland and EA, yeah, again, ruined it.
Yay, yay, yay.
Do we hey, yeah? Yeah, we hey, yeah.
Sorry to ruin your day, but that's true.
What other games?
Dishonoured was good.
Stealth was a bit funny at times,
but definitely happy to play that again.
I'm gonna burp, I'm so sorry.
Oh, no, I'm not.
I don't have to be professional anymore.
It's Karambit.
Oh, my God, what a terrible man.
I heard Monster Hunter.
Oh, hi, Dempah again.
How's it going, Dempah?
I've heard Monster Hunter has bagpipes in it,
like as a weapon, but it's the most, like, hardest thing to play
instead of, like, a sword.
Dishonoured, good, yeah, good.
I'm drawing while watching you.
Did you guys know that Dempah
created her own VTuber art model?
Isn't that amazing?
That's, like, literally so talented.
Talented as in terms of all her hard-working effort
and blood, sweat and tears that she's put into
honing her craft and art.
I read this thing ages ago about artists being, like,
we don't really like it when you say it's, like,
overnight talent, because it's not.
It's, like, you honed your craft
and, like, you should be proud of honing your craft.
You didn't just spawn in as an artist, you know?
Gifted, that's it, you're not gifted.
You honed your craft, you spent years on it.
You got your XP bar raised.
Anyway, that's just my small rant about being nice to artists.
They aren't gifted, they have spent years
specialising into a skill bar, okay?
Thank you.
More VTuber babies.
Oh, you know what game I really liked?
I say this every time is, um, what is it called?
College or a ghost alien mode was so good.
I don't care what anyone says.
It's so very good.
I could for you any young.
We in boys with Denver.
Denver, Denver.
Sorry, I said it from my voice.
Yeah, notice there's no Halo 2,
because I never got a chance to play it.
No, there is, is Halo not there?
Wait, Halo 2 should be there.
I played all the Halo's.
Hold on, Analyze, Analyze them in.
Zoom in. Analyzing.
Oh wait, okay, I can grab it.
Where is it?
It's a place for debut.
There we go.
Analyzing where Halo 2, Halo 2, Halo 2 unidentified.
Okay, I guess.
I have played all the Halo's.
I wanted to, I've not played the new Red Dead Redemption.
Oh my God.
Well, it's not new.
It's been out for years now by this point,
but definitely do Assassin's Creed.
We're 100% doing Ezio's storyline.
I'm going to be really controversial.
Couldn't be a shite once they killed Ezio off.
I mean, he had three installments.
It's not like he was killed off.
Wait, what?
I didn't know it fit.
Does that not fit you?
What?
You should be there.
Okay, I did it, I did it.
Alien isolation, get to fuck.
I'm not playing that game.
That's a terrible game.
Wait, what is?
That's chat.
That's not background music.
Halo?
You need to be above?
Yeah, jeez.
Wait, no, chat.
Oh my God, sorry.
I'm having a stroke.
And not the good kind.
Best Assassin's Creed Brotherhood.
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood is the best Assassin's Creed
installment of all time.
I am not taking any questions, statements,
arguments, or bomb threats to Veiler headquarters.
I'm sorry.
It's just a bit.
I will explain.
We're playing it tomorrow.
I will explain to you chapter by chapter,
step by step on why it's just the most perfect
thought out, like, optimized game for, like,
gameplay.
Just every, I will, I will explain it all.
I'm actually making a video essay about Assassin's
Creed Brotherhood.
It's going to be one of my donuts on rewards.
I've already recorded the footage to do it.
I just need to write the script and everything.
But, like, I kid you not, I'm doing, like, a video essay
40 minutes long.
I don't care.
I'm, like, going to fill Tizmo and Lush.
Okay, we've been on games for quite a while now.
I'm, like, you guys are probably sick of staring at these
games.
Um, how did that not?
I don't think I've done this wrong.
Hey, hello.
Uh, I think I've said all the games.
Yeah.
Oh, we're playing old-school Rinske.
Eight hour Assassin's Creed Brotherhood lore coming in.
What have I done?
Probably, like, less than an hour.
Um, yes, probably, uh, old-school Rinscape is our weekend
game.
It's going to be mostly a multiplayer game for this month
until June 19th when the Eldon...
Wait, why the fuck is there two?
Oh, I must have missed one.
Um, you've never played RuneScape.
Don't worry, we're doing questing.
My only problem with old-school RuneScape is I think you have
to pay the premium experience for premium or we're all just
going to get shafted playing that game, like, not in a good
way.
Um, but yes, Eldon Ring DLC comes out on the 19th and then
the multiplayer game for, like, four days in a row.
I'm doing multiplayer games.
You need to teach me old-school RuneScape.
Literally, I just go fishing at the back of Lumbridge.
Lummi Castle.
Not the back, next to the main bit south of the castle.
Um, but I, uh, what was the single word?
Oh, probably four days of multiplayer Eldon Ring.
And then I have a very unique stream come in with the first
collab outside of Vealor at the end of the month with a
feature called Sin Sister.
And we may or may not have both purchased shock collars,
which we will give each other control of the shock collars.
And we are going to play multiplayer Eldon Ring and whoever
causes us to die, whichever one causes us to die, gets to
shock them, basically.
Yep, we are, we're doing that.
Um, I believe Sheeby is also getting a shock collar, so I
might have some sort of stream with her relating to that.
Uh, I use the shock collar for FaDempa.
Um, but yeah, my goals are pretty much.
I want to do a hundred days of my collabs with VTubers.
It's like a challenge for myself.
I like forcing myself to go talk to people.
Like, I was scared of Dempa, okay, but I DMed her first
because I'm a big girl and I was like, hi, I'm 20.
Uh, would you like to say, I was like, oh yeah, would you like to
collab with me?
She's like, fuck yeah, oh my god, that was so good.
So yeah, Dempa based.
Uh, yes, I'm going to put myself out there, talk to VTubers,
mingle a bit more because, um, I say my voice is cracked.
I said, well, actually you died zap, true.
Uh, everything else is explanatory.
Uh, I need to actually purchase the Lord of the Ring book,
we'll get there, we'll get there.
Okay, this I need help with.
Um, I actually genuinely need help.
I literally have, I don't know if you can hear that.
I have pen and paper to write down what you guys think.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Do I look like, do I look like I'm not smart?
Wait, hold on, let me write it down.
General, like, sorry, I'm going to look down every time I do this.
Art.
Old art.
Mean.
And obviously you flings or waflings.
Dempa is intimidating until you realize our tentacles can go.
Hmm.
You're so, so, so.
Keeping, keep them all as help.
Okay.
Strawing.
Oh, that's actually kind of cute.
Yeah, um, cuddle time.
Yeah, I'm, I'll Dempa, I'm with you.
Like, I just like straightforward stuff.
Gen, like, strong gen, strong gen, strong live, strong clip,
strong art, strong old art, strong meme.
Straw notes.
Straw notes would make sense.
Snort.
Snort, snort, snort, snort.
It's not like what, uh,
it's not like what a swan would say.
Snort.
Uh, general refers to, um, if you just want to say something,
like on Twitter, you use that,
and then, like, I'll read it with my eyeballs.
Straw live.
Honestly, my voice is cracking now.
I'm not gonna make it.
I can't believe it.
If I can debut and already did,
not even 24 hours later.
Strong lure.
I guess I said.
Ink time.
Oh my god, ink time.
Sorry, ink time for art.
That has to be, that's so good.
Ink time.
I like ink time.
Yeah, like a reaction tag.
Strong sea.
Oh!
Strong seas?
Like I see.
Strong leaks.
I think ink time is good.
Because ink myself is my,
my, my other catchphrase.
It's not catchphrase at all.
Strong memes.
Stronetized.
Oh, let's do that.
The inking.
Anything.
Oh.
Sorry, I'm itching my eyeball.
Strong bad.
Oh god, I'm so bad at this.
Strong close.
I mean, just do what DEMPA said,
and just, like, strong gen,
strong live, strong this, strong that.
Ink time was used by a tattoo artist.
Man, tattoo artist out here,
ruining it for all of us.
We dafty, we dafty.
I inked myself.
Strong Sina.
Oh, that's actually really good.
Hold on.
General text, strong Sina.
I'll just do one N.
That's so good.
I've seen you.
Strong Sina.
Strong sake.
No!
No, Vsake.
I'll never beat the Vsake allegation.
Be for yourself.
I think Street 4 would meet fans soon.
Mimire.
It sounds like Namorize.
And I have the memory of a goldfish.
Incredible.
I'll turn out funny.
Gen can be strong.
You know what?
Any mention of my absolutely horrific
Strawfish.
Stratustive.
God, I'm so bad at this.
I'll think.
I'll need to freaking cook on it more.
I don't want to be stuck.
Smallfish.
Oh, smallfish is really good for all art.
Oh, yeah.
Smallfish.
I'm putting that down.
I hate when you have to like TTL.
E?
Oh, I did too many of them.
What's that?
I can't read it right properly.
Yet my entire career is based on it.
Hell yeah.
Okay, we'll move on.
I'll come back to it.
I'll cook a little on my own.
Obviously, Squishy Gold pretty much.
He did designs, lores.
There's actually full lores, Will.
I can't read it right now because my voice is perishing.
Um, what else?
Mascots.
All the mascots were made.
If you didn't know the reason,
I'll heal your throat with your tentacles, please.
The reason why reeflings have a patch on their head
is a nicotine patch to help you with your addiction.
We have an addiction to each other.
So that's why you have a nicotine patch.
And you have lovely tentacles.
I've already got lots of suspicious artwork of us together,
but it's for November, so I can't post that.
Yeah, Tamachi absolutely cooked on the lores.
Background, yeah, I love my room.
Odd's Top was such a good sport.
I literally sent them a DM.
I'm like, hey, can you base it off of Sonic OST?
And he's like, yeah, sure.
Waltz with me.
He did my little banner that's on Twitter,
which is really good, absolutely.
Azura could help you all with her healing properties.
Oh really?
Yeah, Small Sushi, she did great.
Small Sushi actually, she did fantastic
because the girls weren't fully conceptualized
when she created them.
I basically just gave descriptions,
which was really rough.
I know you haven't seen my stingers
for my scene transitions.
I hate stingers.
I spent like $200,
and I don't even want to use them.
I bought it, obviously I bought it for everyone else,
but I'm like, why did I spend that money on me?
I don't like using stingers.
I just went straight into it.
And my loading screen was so expensive.
Actually, Umi cooked with the loading screen.
She's actually making another alternative version
because I had to do that cover-up thing.
But that was very expensive as well.
I just want to get in there.
And then obviously why I picked my gen.
That was so fun to do.
Everyone's like, oh, this is my first impression.
No, motherfucker.
I picked them.
Oh, so fun.
It was so fun being able to say that
and being like, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely adored it.
Evil strongy be like, I always use stingers.
I love stingers.
I love when VTubers have 10 minutes of stream starting soon
at the start of their streams.
Perish, absolutely perish.
Nonsense.
I'm starting up on a brotherhood at the menu tomorrow.
Mark my words.
But yes.
It was just fantastic.
The girls, it's hard to judge people when they apply
because it just felt really...
weird.
Hold on.
Yeah, it felt weird trying to put them on
because some of them said put me on any model.
Some of them said I wanted a specific model.
I think Azura got who she wanted.
She be...
Hmm.
Mercy wanted AC.
AC wanted AC, so AC got AC.
Amy, did Amy say anyone?
Anyway, it's impossible to give people the outline
that they wanted because they couldn't even see it.
They couldn't even see it.
It was just an outline.
Did you have any awkward or weird applications?
Someone's intro video was 30 seconds.
For anyone watching, if you're serious about joining
a VTuber agency, what you're supposed to roughly do
in an application introduction video
is to say your accolades,
whatever you achieved as a streamer
prior to what you're doing now.
So you mention how often you stream.
Do you stream three times a week consistently?
Good thing to mention.
30 seconds.
It was like, hi, I'm...
and I stream on and that was it.
And I was like, bro, what am I supposed to do with that?
But yeah, you're supposed to say your accolades,
what you want to achieve within the agency,
is a good thing to mention.
You're also supposed to pass the test
where you say hi, Valor, at the start
because that means you read the instructions properly.
If you didn't start with hi, Valor,
I didn't close your application right away.
I gave you a chance, but it's kind of one of those tests
where those who did it, I know you read.
Those who didn't, either, you forgot.
Although I say that,
I mean, the girls have given me permission
to kind of talk about the thing.
Azura's application was unprofessional.
Fuck, I'm not even going to be around the bush with Azura.
She gave me permission to talk about it.
In her introduction, she was like, hey, I'm Azura.
And she was like, I really don't like pickles
and I don't like mustard.
And I was like, Azura, this is your introduction video.
You're supposed to tell me things you've achieved.
She's like, yeah, I don't like the taste of these certain foods.
And I was like, you're perfect for the hag, and you come.
You're perfect for the doting hag
that we've got no competition.
I say, doesn't even, English isn't even her first language.
She had the most professional application.
She had these massive paragraphs, serious answers.
Amy was a dafty.
She freaking forgot to edit one part of her application.
And in one of the answers,
she was like, I want to diddle the other girls.
And I'm like, I knew it was an oversight
because everything else was professional.
I'm like, any one earth have you put.
She failed the high vealure.
Mercy must have watched her introduction video
like 30 times over.
She was so like, she went above and beyond.
She actually created Icy.
Like recreated her outline and named her and all of that.
Pocha, Amy left that on purpose.
Yeah.
The introduction video gives me a very good hint
to what kind of beach over you are.
No, what kind of person you are
because there's one thing to stream,
but when you're talking directly to someone who's assessing you,
you act a bit different.
And yes, it was very interesting.
It was very interesting.
I got serenaded so much.
So I don't know why I'm frog blinking.
Let me just give me one second.
She's going to totally not recalibrate in the old mech.
Hold on.
That's very calibration.
Yeah, I got serenaded.
So many people were singing.
I'm like, you don't have to sing to be in this agency.
You just need to do one cover song of it.
I'm not going to force you to sing.
Probably one of the most frustrating things
was we asked to have streaming history
and people's evidence of being a streamer
was like a link to their Twitter and no other thing.
Oh no, content creator.
That was the terminology used.
You have to be a content creator.
And it was like, are you okay?
Why are you linking your Twitter?
Twitter isn't content.
There weren't even a v-tweet or anything like that.
And it was just like...
Are the girls doing more songs?
Yes, 100%.
If the girls want to pursue more singing,
they just come to me and tell me what they want to do.
And I get that she don't.
Well, other things.
Obviously, I'm not going to say anything private.
I'm very flattered.
There were some very big names that applied,
but they just weren't a good fit.
Or they already had a pre-established brand
and it was like, is this really what you want?
I think you just want to...
I think some people that were very high notoriety
were interested more in the manager side of things
than actually being at the other.
We had like one person who was fricking massive
and they were like, can I keep my IP and join you?
And I'm like, sorry.
I need to own the rights to the models
in order to do what we need to do.
Okay.
It was a shame,
because I'm sure that person would have done just fine,
but it's not possible to not have the IP
and utilize the girls.
Yes, it was in the facts on the page.
The website got so many fucking questions
that were answered on the website,
so they had to ignore the tab that had all the information
to go to the contact part of the website
to then ask the question,
that was already on the website.
Literally, I tried so hard to make that ship
be as comprehensible as possible.
Yes, I think the applicants definitely read through it all.
Reef time.
Oh, I can't say that.
Sorry, I'm not...
That's the code name.
I did not say that word.
Please don't get on me.
I'm just trying to think back
because there's anything notable on the applications.
Oh my God!
There was one application.
She was outrageous.
Outrageous.
If you apply to an agency,
that agency watches your content.
This girl, my goodness,
she applied.
I went on her Twitch to listen to her live
to check her out and all of that.
She admitted in the next live stream,
oh, I'd only do Vialure for one year
and then bring my audience over to this account.
Why would you admit that out loud?
I'm very happy to see it.
I never even considered her,
but oh my God, how could you be so...
I don't even know what the word is.
I was gobsmacked.
I sent it to other members of the team
to make sure I heard what I heard was correct.
But they outright said,
yeah, I would just do it for one year
and then bring my audience over.
Dog.
Thank God I didn't waste.
Waste a slot for you.
I am very happy to say that all current talents
have given very high indications
of staying at the agency, you know,
as long as income is all good and dandy.
So please do support them via Patreon
or monetization streams when the girls get monetized.
But yes, I was absolutely gobsmacked.
One to even apply to do it in the first place
knowing you have no commitment,
knowing that we're like 80, 20 split,
everything's in your favor, 100% merch,
and saying that you're not even going to be, like, dedicated.
Oh my God.
And then to admit it,
to admit it,
knowing you submitted yourself and the agency
is watching over you.
Oh my God.
Absolutely gobsmacked.
Oh.
Anyway,
I will repeat again,
I am very happy to say that all girls
have given indications of long-term commitment,
if you will.
And as well as,
if they sign on for one more year,
like another year,
the split goes 85 to them,
15 to the agency,
and they also get an alternative outfit on us.
They do not pay for it, we pay for it.
I'm glad she was honest, I didn't waste her time.
She was honest in her stream,
she was not honest on her application form,
to fill all of that out in mislead and be like,
I'm just going to quit after a year,
just go,
I actually spat in real life
and that landed on my phone.
Don't do that, don't fuck with me.
I put a lot of love into this.
Women lie, I can't believe it, that's terrible.
You know you can't say that,
that's the concept artist by the way,
don't believe the thing that comes out of his mouth.
I'm jealous of the phone.
I didn't know she was going to do that bit
on her debut, where she was like,
I gasped, I was like, oh my god.
Just so you guys know,
I didn't have anything to do with her debuts,
they all did it themselves.
I was like, oh my god.
Anyway,
oh,
2.0's over, right, show's over folks.
Um,
I'm a bit jealous.
Right, I'm going to open up Marshmallow
because this time I can answer a question.
Please keep my UKatha on.
I don't know what letter did it,
but I can actually answer Marshmallows that are,
um,
why are you so cute? Stop it,
my voice is so freaking broken.
Have you considered streaming elsewhere?
Yes, the girls are allowed to stream on an alternative website
at a later date.
Please understand,
we are trying to establish yourself on YouTube at first,
and we have monetization on YouTube,
and the girls' income is all sorted.
But yes, there are plans.
I will make it free access.
I do not believe in charging any further
than, um,
YouTube membership and Patreons all together
at $9.99 for your OSHI desk to support,
because it is $1.99 for emotes
to make sure no one gets gifted membership.
And then is it $4.99, or is it $3.99?
My voice is broken.
Is it $4.99 for membership?
Usually.
Is $4.99, yeah, $4.99 seen agreeable.
Okay, $1.99 for tier one, $4.99.
Yeah, that sounds right, that sounds right.
Um, as long as you guys don't think it's outrageous,
like in this day and age.
Um, as I've said in the Veil or Smoothstream,
we are undercutting the market.
Um, I'm not even going to pretend otherwise.
On the VA side of things,
most VA's start at $10 for two exclusive audios.
We are undercutting the market by doing
four audios for $5.
And no price increase at all is planned.
And if you feel ever so inclined,
you can donate more via, donate.
You can support more via Patreon.
There is a secondary tier that is $20, I believe.
I haven't put anything else in place.
Um, yes.
What's your history with hypnosis?
I'm learning, I'm a new baby.
Um, but I'm going to give it my best shot.
I have a very deep interest in it.
I've just never actually made content about it, like, straight up.
It's not expensive, yes, I...
Oh, I really, I've heard some stories
around that it was going to be $5 for standard and $20.
Oh, no, no, we're undercutting the market.
$5 and you get four, four audios per month.
Um, are you concerned undercutting could cause a scene?
Wide price shift downwards?
No, because prices are going up everywhere.
Um, following the voice actress trends
and the ASMR side of things and the role play side of things,
prices are only going up and I believe in the opposite.
I believe in delivering both quality and quantity.
Um, without overworking the girls, please understand
that management have dictated the scripts for a couple of months.
However, there's few girls interested in writing their scripts.
I'm also very open to writing scripts live.
Unfortunately, there will be a membership stream.
For me, content-wise, to give you guys exactly what you're looking for.
Um, but please understand, I cannot pigeonhole the girls
into doing the same thing over and over again.
Just rehashed, that's not, that's not, um,
that is no way for them to be set up for success.
That is, they will be set up for failure, sadly, if I did that
and I really hope, uh, yeah.
Have you written any scripts yet?
Yeah, you listened to them.
Everything that's out right now on Patreon is done by me.
The two other script writers kick in, I want to say roughly in three months
and then the manager for the scripts is about to kick in.
I don't know quite what's happening yet, if they'll write the majority.
Um, this is just my humble opinion, but because I don't have...
My scripts do not come out as best as if a man had written it.
That's just my opinion.
Um, the Emmy has shown interest in a script,
Shibi has shown interest in writing.
I think Azura prefers the help.
Azura, um, I think she needs reassurance.
AC is good at improv.
Uh, I think she may do some improv scripts in the future.
Uh, yes.
What is the adult aspect to the agency?
Uh, the alternate, alt-twitters and, uh, Patreon.
Yeah.
Azura did good.
She did.
I eventually want to be a member for all the girls who girls deserve their fans.
Uh, yeah, I'll kind of repeat this.
If you, like, are in a position where you can support, like, one girl,
please think about supporting the other girls over me.
Um, I am living a very good life, um, and things are going very well.
Please don't worry about me, okay?
How do you find the alternate of twitters?
Check who they're following?
Yeah, check who they're following.
Question about your design.
How did you come up with the twin tails?
And the candy piece is seashells!
I'm a cuttlefish, I'm a sea beacherber.
Uh, these are cuttlefish, uh, sorry, these are seashells.
Uh, and then I got double bunches.
Um, I love symmetrical hair, and I love bunches, so I got double bunches.
Um, would you be open to accepting script submissions?
Absolutely, I don't know how to set it up, I don't know how to do it,
and I don't know, I need, I would need to, like, give a guide,
because it's quite hard behind the scenes to get it all efficient and good to go, but yeah.
Definitely open to it.
Please do let us cook though, like, literally the dust is settling,
the girls are about to start doing game streams after these 2.0s.
Um, the first week I did request the girls to stream as much as they're physically able to
without cancelling streams, I have emphasised to them that cancelling streams,
try your best to not over promise, it's better to take a day off than it is to
um, plan a stream that you think you can do and then you get too tired and cancel it,
because cancelling streams is very, people plan, people plan their time and their days
and their energy around a stream if they know what time it's coming on,
and it's very valuable to respect people's time.
So, like, for reeflings, for example, you guys know that I don't stop streaming,
like, at all, and I'm always there, and I literally have never cancelled a stream, so.
And that's true, I haven't cancelled a stream.
Mm-mm.
Um, sorry to tie it, just to bring the topic back.
Gifted membership is the one that's closest to $5, yeah.
You may have to go higher.
Eh, eto?
I thought gifted membership went to the lowest tier, tier one was gonna be emotes only,
and then tier two was gonna be $4.99.
Ah, I really don't wanna overcharge.
So there is gonna...
Well, wait, more streams?
Yeah, I stream all day every day, baby.
Just make it an extra dollar.
Eh, it's expensive though, it's expensive.
Eh, who goes there?
By the Pope.
Identify yourself.
Um...
I literally said in the interview, you're not gonna get in trouble, I'm not your mum.
I couldn't give less than two shits what you do.
I basically said the only thing I ask you not to do is release any NDA content,
and, you know, don't say the N word.
You know, basic adult stuff.
It's pretty much it.
I mean, I don't know what else to tell you.
When you treat adults like adults, they act like adults.
It's crazy.
Did you hypnotize the girls to become the characters?
Eh, I hope you're drinking a lot of soda.
Ah, I'm going cola.
It's fizzy juice, actually.
Sorry, you're turning Scots.
It's not soda, it's fizzy juice.
Um, yes.
As for repercussions, like I said, we don't do suspensions.
However, I did warn them.
I said, doesn't mean you're allowed free reign.
Like, we can cut, we can terminate.
Obviously, we don't want to do that.
And no girl has given any indication of any of that shit.
Thank God.
I have full faith in these girls.
I've known them for two months now.
No issues.
Not one issue has popped up.
Oh, yeah, fizzy juice is how you say it in Scotland.
Are you a hire up in the agency?
No.
I said, don't call me boss.
I basically got their script started,
but it's going to a script manager.
And I don't have to do any work.
I get to stream all day long.
Um...
Yeah, someone kind of asked about Gentoo.
A year away, bro.
A year away.
Do you plan on doing movie watch alongs?
Absolutely.
Well, you ever do a deep sea creature list?
Oh my God, yeah, that's so good.
That's a good idea.
I like that.
I was going to...
So this is a failed stream idea.
I was actually going to order, like, a cuttlefish.
It wouldn't be alive,
but I wanted to explore the biology of it
because I think they're pretty cool.
Like cephalopods are pretty cool.
And I wanted to, like, show you guys, like,
there's a thing.
If I was a cuttlefish, I'd say, look, looks good.
But I think people would find it a bit more
that I'm, like, essentially playing with a dead body.
So...
Yeah, probably can do that.
I've not played Subnautica.
I don't have a memory of playing it.
Could give it a good shot.
I could recommend it.
But it's for science.
Cephalopog!
For memes?
Cephalopog.
Sorry.
My tag now,
as long as no one's yoinked it.
Hold on, hold on.
Let me scroll up so I can see the spelling.
Thank you!
Yoinkers!
My tag now!
Which tags are missing?
I've got strong Sina for general.
I've got smuttlefish for all
and cephalopog for memes.
So I need live clips and art.
Cracked it.
Literally didn't even have to come up with it myself.
What a genius.
Hee hee.
Let me refresh my...
I scroll down a bit, actually.
As long as they're respectful,
I'll actually use it for educational content.
Yeah, I like biology,
but I think people find it quite morbid sometimes.
I don't want to upset anyone.
I can't believe you're already taking advantage of me.
True.
You like it, really?
I've missed taking advantage of you.
What a refund.
Tentacles.
I don't have any tentacles.
I may get tentacles another time,
but I don't have tentacles.
I feel like if I had tentacles,
they would come out with my...
I'll be honest,
I don't think they would be tailbone attached.
I think they would come out with my other end.
Out of all the girls,
who do you think is going to overwork themselves for Sheebie?
Sheebie's already done so much work in advance,
so she can focus on streams.
Um...
The tentacles not be around you.
Oh my god, someone took the Scottish coffee pasta.
What do you think of that, Mr. Pajama wearing
basket face, slipper wielding...
I hate...
The only thing I don't like about Marshmallow
is that it cuts words in the middle.
Like...
Tentacles.
Ooh, that became cool.
Do any of the girls have any talents,
which is a surprise to you?
Emmy, please, piano for real, for real.
Um...
Mercy...
has acting.
Um...
Is there a draw?
Sheebie actually draws as well,
and Mercy and Emmy,
and A.C. Doodle.
Um...
I think they all draw,
and I'm like, fuck Nella.
These are all talents, and what do I do?
I just sound like a backpipe.
Hipstone, like, that's good.
Um...
Will the talents keep their silver playbots?
Of course, Jesus, why would I keep that?
That's disgusting.
Absolute disgusting behaviour.
All their hard work, and I keep the playbutton.
Absolutely not.
Oh my God, someone said an hour ago,
when will auditions be open for Gen 2?
I am hot and ready like a little
Caesar's Pizza.
Come and scoop me up before a rich man does.
I've spotted an American...
Bevin' on.
Um...
Mimi on reflex.
Oh my God, I need to make a reflex...
post...
on my alternate arm.
My voice is so loud.
Mummy, thank you for giving me a little sister.
You talked prior during the selection process
about keeping a list...
a list of possible candidates,
so I got my first choice for everyone.
I don't know how,
but everyone was like first choice pick.
I wanted them in the agency, they came in the agency.
There were...
I would say like...
eight people...
that were like...
all back.
Obviously Azura didn't have one,
that was a problem.
Emmy, I was actually really worried
she wouldn't accept her board.
She likes it.
I was worried that she wouldn't accept the board.
And she was like, yeah, that's fine, I don't care.
I was like, okay, then jeez, jeez.
I was worried she wouldn't accept that.
Have any Japanese carpo's influenced
your decision making?
Why do you believe there was
no lid one before?
No idea.
Probably because
you need someone who's done it
before to even understand
what to do.
A lot of guy owned corporations
in the nicest way,
most likely haven't been streamers before
and don't comprehend what you're asking
people to do.
I kind of spoke about this a wee bit
in the last stream.
That 80-20 split,
in order to motivate people,
you have to let them earn what they're worth.
If you turn around and say to them,
for every $100
you're getting
20 bucks out of it, you're getting 50 bucks out of it,
all that girl
is going to be doing is sitting there
saying, oh wow,
I could have made the full 100 on my alt account.
Oh wow, I could have done this on my previous life.
That's all that they're going to sit there
and think.
We're talking pure business, baby.
I'm happy to talk pure business if you want.
Well, the monthly audio releases
be revealed before the month starts.
Yes, we need to
get on top of that.
Sadly, there was a few issues
production wise
with a few things.
Surprise, surprise, turns out,
takes a lot of time to make these things happen.
Love artists, but my fucking god,
can you not go over deadlines?
That'd be great.
But yes, we
will be posting monthly
what the tags are,
what the title is.
We just need to catch up.
You need to give us time to breathe.
I'm so sorry, all I can ask is your patience.
Unironically, bow emoji
because
we need time.
It was absolutely hectic
on debut.
We were exhausted in that group collab
and
I don't know if you recognise
how fast we ended.
I was like, right, say bye to chat, bye.
We all
disappeared out of that voice call so quickly.
I was like, thank you guys so much.
I'm going to wait a pass out.
And then I ended up being really sick after it.
But yes,
we just need things to calm down.
We're going to ease into the first week.
Everyone's got their games. You get to see their personalities
more, enjoy them more, which is fantastic.
We know that.
And
octopus.
I'm not an octopus.
I'm a cod-o-fish.
No call me octopus.
No call me squid.
I'm a cephalopod
or a cod-o-fish.
Better take your yourselves.
And now the things have calmed down.
The lead up to debut is very nerve-wracking.
Like, very, very nerve-wracking.
I have finished my cola.
I will now start on
my warble.
Astronaut, you're so friggin...
Hey, you like my teeth?
Is that what I was doing it for you?
I think I've caught up a little bit.
I don't know.
I lied.
Is there a reason you went with YouTube over Twitch?
Yes, I can manage the girls' accounts from YouTube.
I cannot manage the girls' accounts from Twitch.
I can't do a thing on Twitch,
management-wise.
And
Twitch, unfortunately,
are very sparse and arbitrary
when they
throw the old ban hammer down
or suspension hammer down.
Really not a fan of Twitch doing that.
Every week you see
a girl being like, Twitch with a heck.
I'm literally doing everything
that everyone...
I'm doing stuff that everyone else does.
Like, it just...
At least with YouTube,
you can beg them on Twitter
for help or whatever.
Twitch is inconsistent, yeah.
Let's see.
Would you dominate
Inkling?
I've never played Splatoon.
Isn't it actually good?
It's probably the most lore-friendly
game for me to play.
How does managing accounts...
Yeah, so I have a...
It sounds really bad, but I don't do anything
on their accounts, but
I can basically go on their accounts
and set up streams for them
or approve comments for them.
Anything they want to help out, really.
Now that
debuts have happened, the girls are
going to be controlling all that stuff.
They'll be doing their live streams and stuff,
but in order to reduce as much
stress as possible on the girls,
I pretty much try to do every single
little thing, but
now that we're past the debut stage,
they're going to have to be big girls
now and, you know,
put up their little games,
put up their streams
and all that and update their description.
Like, I was the one doing
all that behind the scenes.
Have you played Pokmon? Yeah, Pokmon Ruby.
My childhood game.
Um...
Mudkip was my starter.
They have to spread their big girl wings.
Yes, I like putting a message in the
Discord. I'm like, I'm so sorry girls,
but the hand holding kind of
slows down now.
Um...
Oh yeah.
Say hello out.
It was torturing.
Blaziken is so strong
and so is Mudkip. Mudkip's really strong
as well.
Mudkip's always used in speedruns
for Pokmon Ruby or Emerald.
She doesn't know
I want to collect her ink. Oh my god.
Inks on you.
Strony is mum a bird, but it's time for them to flee the nest.
Honestly, like,
um, I hope
overall they feel like less stressed.
Like, um...
They didn't have to think
about the lures or what they wanted to say.
Everything was edited on their behalf.
Like, they had to give the audios over,
everything was done on their behalf.
Because like, I've heard stories
of, like, other
agencies, like,
go to the talent, right, make up your lure.
We've ordered all the art, but you make up the lure, by the way.
And it's like, what?
You literally are handing me the model. What do you mean you've not
thought this stuff? And it was like, quick
come up with a description of your character really quickly,
quickly, quick, quick!
And it's like, what?
You're giving me the model.
What do you mean I come up with this stuff?
Like, that's the whole point of the model, unless it would be customized?
Like, it's just like, fuck.
Um...
How did you
end up managing them? Or are you new to the agency?
Well, I'm new to being a manager. I'm not even their manager.
I'm just a streamer that does it alongside them.
I just picked them!
But, but me?
Me? Nah, I'm on Assassin's Creed.
I'm fucking being a boss. I ain't doing
shit.
Um...
Yeah.
I know this isn't...
Someone said it! Someone said say
Purple Burglar Alarm! Got it!
I knew someone was going to say it. I always
get asked this. Right.
So in my, like, clear accent,
I say Purple Burglar Alarm.
But if I say it in a harsh Scottish accent,
Purple Burglar Alarm?
Like, my tongue gets caught
on the top of the roof of my mouth. Wait, I'll mute
my background music so you can really hear it.
My tongue gets caught.
Purple Burglar Alarm?
Like, ooh!
You can hear my tongue getting caught.
Say it, huh?
Hmm...
Uh-uh...
Sorry, Paul.
Uh...
What did you miss? Nothing.
It's just me memein' about...
Are you all trying to keep non-conflicting
schedules? Sadly, it's not
possible when someone like me is on the team.
Um, so whenever
a gen mate of mine goes
live, I will highly recommend
you go watch them. Cause right now, for example,
Shiba Cottenbom is live doing her 2.0.
Uh, Azura is coming
on in roughly three hours.
Um, but sadly
I am an endurance streamer
and the best time slot that I have selected
means that I can go to doctors' appointments
even if I do. Um... No, I'm not dying!
Before anyone freaking types that
I'm fine, my health is good.
Um...
Uh, it's all good. Don't worry.
Um, but the time slot
I have chosen means that I can still go out
to do things like go shoppin
or to a doctor's appointment
or, um,
you know, go feed gammy, you know how it is.
I'm not dying!
Stop! My health is so much better.
Although I do have a sad story.
I mean, I won't say it in 2.0
even though it's just
our wealth.
Nah, nah, I'll keep it to myself cause it's a bit sad
and I don't want to make you guys sad.
Like, this is such a good happy time. Like, holy fuck, we're back.
Um, after a year
goddamn, that took so long to cook!
But we're here!
Strongly cut.
Me, that's just my name.
Admitted, that's just my name.
Um...
But yeah, sadly I am an
Endurance streamer which means
weekly I will most likely have very long streams
that are not
friendly to the majority of viewers.
Please understand, do not feel
bad.
If you are unable to watch me
live.
The other girls
might be much more accessible to you
time zone wise or stream wise.
I can still hear her
fuck!
But I play, I absolutely
do not feel insulted at all
if you cannot
you know, keep up with me.
I'm not very friendly, my time zone
isn't friendly, I am aware of that.
And cause I'm an Endurance streamer, like, tomorrow's stream
is literally
8 hours long.
I'm not even kidding. We're doing the full play
through of Assassin's Creed Brotherhood
and then we're going back to 100% it
cause I've never 100%
in the DNA sequence since Assassin's
Creed Brotherhood before. Like, that's what
we're doing the next day.
What do you mean? I thought you were just debuting.
So yeah,
that's why
whenever a gen mate
goes live, please, you are more than welcome
to tell me. I will direct
you guys to the gen mate cause I can't
redirect cause my stream, my gate
if my stream isn't over.
So full play through
first day is planned, yes, and then 100%
the next day, I don't know how long it's
gonna take, but yeah.
8 hours isn't
gonna be the norm every single stream
so like, for example,
for example
needy streamer overload
is
2 hours long, I think.
I've never played the game before
I think it's just a click simulator
type thing. I'm not sure.
I've also got
however, actually
James Cameron's
avatars an 8 hour
stream, sorry.
Old school
RuneScape is like 12 hours, oh god.
These are all so long.
I need to make up for lost time.
Not to mention, once I get
membership, once I get monetized
I'm also doing membership streams
on top of all of this.
8 hour stream on Saturday
and then
I'm trying foreign sweets.
It is gonna be like a
like a desk
camp. Oh, yeah.
Oh, you get to see my desk, man.
When do you
rest?
I will rest until I'm dead.
I've waited a year to be here.
I have lost time to make up for.
People have waited
in cryo freeze for me for a very long time.
And the way I say
thank you is
rather than saying thank you
is like doing it through content, through ASMR,
through collabs, through everything.
So, yeah.
I'm
making up for it. Oh, no.
Someone says
don't burn out, please.
I have a secret for you.
I have this thing, your honor.
It's called rautism.
And it means I actually don't
experience burnout.
I don't experience it.
I basically
go to sleep and wake up the next day
and I'm ready to take on the world again.
I've never really felt
what burnout is, the way people describe it.
I think
my autism has given me a buff
and
means I don't get burnout.
And I'm very excited to stream every single day.
It's a superpower.
Yes, for the foreign sweet stream,
again, that's hand cam.
You'll see my hands. So, if you don't like VTubers
that can show
a wee bit of the flesh. Do apologize.
I might not be for you. However, do have
gen mates that are a little shy
and I don't think they'll show themselves.
So, please be patient.
I'm autistic.
Don't send me a picture of my face
with the hat right now.
So, I can make it my twitter
profile picture right now.
I need to make it my twitter profile picture.
Strontism.
Strontism is...
Oh, should that be my life tag?
Because I don't get burnout.
Strontism.
Oh, that's really bad though. I feel like
you're making fun of autism. I'm like
one shut the fuck up. I literally
have sweaty hands and feet all day long.
Like, fuck you.
You gotta throw a swirl at them.
Swirl at them.
I like that hypnosis swirls. It's like this thing
you swirl on a desk and then you're like
strontism.
Life tag strontism.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can blame you guys if someone's like
oh my god, you're making fun of autism.
Shut the fuck up.
Anyway, I don't think anyone's
going to watch me that's like that anyway, so.
Never seen a work horse.
Ooh.
I guess it's even better than this
when the memberships come out.
Strontism is...
shit in Dutch.
Ain't no way.
Ain't no way I name
myself Kaka in Netherlands.
Netherlands.
Netherlands Praten.
Nee jong.
Ik snap het niet.
Ik heb namen.
Wait, I forgot all the Dutch in the world.
My name
is
Merda. That's terrible.
I have autism too. Oh my god, autism gang.
Gang gang gang gang.
Got the Patreon.
Yeah.
Did you like my Patreon audio? Did you like the demo?
It was so weird.
Like hearing
hearing the
the Scots.
You know what I'm saying.
The demo audio was good.
Aw, thank you.
Eh.
You didn't tell us you could speak Dutch.
Nee, ik kan niet.
Was it
Ik leer Netherlands
on dat
Ik heb
I had
Netherlands
Mensen, Vrenden,
Vrijden. That's German.
I basically used to play Call of Duty with some Dutch folk.
And then, yeah.
Learn some Dutch.
Learn some French as well.
Like if you want to say
justice reigns from above in French.
Don't worry.
I've got you, okay?
Place au deluge de la justice.
Dutch is so funny.
Azura was like, I'm learning Dutch.
I'm like, Azura, oh my god.
Azura, I'll teach you.
I'll teach you how to say turtle, okay?
You say, oh no!
My phone's on 20% battery.
No.
Sorry, my phone is what I
I pilot my neck on.
I'm so, ah, my arms are
shaking.
Did you hear?
Hello?
Wake up!
Okay, there we go.
I just put my charger in.
It's fine, it's fine.
Everything's fine.
Stop!
Please, please hold still.
No, I'm sorry.
Please hold still.
Ah, please!
Wrong, wrong, wrong!
Oh my god, my PC's screaming at me right now.
You guys still see me?
You guys are like, horizontal
on my desk right now.
I'm sorry.
Also, I'm really sorry
if you're like immersive featureverse.
I'm really bad at this shit!
I'm piloting my neck on.
I'm doing a terrible job.
You're literally horizontal
on my desk right now.
I'm looking down at you like, hi!
This is terrible!
Okay, let me have some more.
Abagando las luces.
Let's see.
The ace.
I mean, it's working, it's working.
I'm just looking a bit funny.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Alright, let me refocus.
Let me refocus!
Get it? Cause you're a refling!
Six, Griffin, Griffin!
I need to make an audio
of a certain nature
where I just say reforming over and over.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh, my trigong!
Stopping phone!
There's pilot in this met, who's driving this bus?
Please phone, just stay still!
Stop wiggling!
Okay, I'm actually I'm gonna start I'm gonna start turning Scots in a minute. I'm getting raging go and just actual sit still
I've got like what freakin give me like 30 minutes of you being still see right wait hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold the phone
No, literally hold the phone get it cuz the fucking phone won't try it right hold on
Ah
Okay turns out you can put your iPhone sideways and it still tracks you I didn't know that I've just learned that right now
That's right ladies and gentlemen, I was the one who
Judged you if you're a beach over worthy enough to get in the agency, and I've literally streamed for less than two months myself
I
Absolutely terrible. I shouldn't talk about that. I'm sure there's some people really really pissed that didn't pick them. Sorry. I was your barrier
But please understand we also took into
Someone can have the perfect voice
Okay, I'm fine. Ah
Go away. I get scared. I get scared when management show up. I'm like
Oh
Leave me alone. Oh, my voice is cracking. Oh crap so much professional
Big well, right? Let me refresh your questions
I want you to strong my cuddles until I
That's such a good sentence. Oh my god
What do you think of sunken gallery
Not convinced
Such operation I know I know I know I know
Was that the melody of legend of zelda?
Um
Will you get multiple endings there's multiple endings I've never played I actually don't know much about the game
I thought it was like you click buttons. That's all I know
That you click buttons you'll never get I'm really good at clicking buttons, you know what I'm saying
They're all bad endings. Oh, no
They're multiple. There's tons of endings. I thought it was like one of them quick games
I
How did you end up getting to pick the talent when you're just new to the agency is there
Because I'm the creative director
I'm the creative director
Good ending is when you get your meds. No, oh, maybe take your meds
And the voices go away, no
I don't want to play elton ring and then take my meds because then you guys all disappear
Oh my god, do you remember that time we played elton ring and we all like
We're mimicking something and then someone came in and went bang bang and blew us all up
How big is the vealer team, I mean it depends if you want to count contractors as well
It gets pretty juicy if you want to count contractors
Like we've literally got like four more technical clippers coming in. No
One person's about to be on trial two are like we want them full-time basically. Um, so that adds more people to the website
Do you count the talents as well? That's another six then technically
If we disappear who will stream side. Oh, oh, yeah, one of you guys have to come in as the baddie. Wait, what's happening with my arm?
Oh, what's happening with my arm?
Oh
No, I'm gonna have to know you about that a little bit. It's a bit too aggressive
Are there any big group projects? Yes. Oh my god
There's such big group projects. I'm so tired
I planned ahead I planned every month. There's gonna be some sort of event going on at the allure
Um
Leave my noodle on. I don't know why my arm breaking
I'll annoy nari about it. Nari was absolutely fantastic when she came to construct in me. She's fantastic
Um
You plan on getting 3d models
Yes, but you're gonna have to put your money where your mouth is if you want to see the girls 3d
Put your money where your mouth is give them memberships. Go on the patrons because
It's expensive because I we would have to buy them the trackers as well
I actually don't know much about 3d in yet, but I'm pretty sure like you can
Be our chat model and we can all like touch each other and stuff in there
And we put you
Will there be group audios yes, there will be group audios and
There's already one-on-one audios planned with each other
But I didn't know the comfortability level of the girls when we were like at that stage of development
So so far it's azura and sheepsters
me and mersey and
emmers and icers
I've not done anything further. I think donathan rewards
Will most likely be targeted at that stuff and it'll be access
free to access
Because I think public donathan rewards are much more satisfactory. Obviously we will have to do the classic
like first place second place third place and because
We do need to incentivize and
Azura and
Might be in the position to move out if all goes well and she gets the support
Like monetary like gets monetized and
All that jazz and if she can move out she can definitely increase her like stream times for you and
Just find a easier tang
That's why I'm kind of like support the others because like they're in positions where like oh if I could move out
I could definitely meet more content stream for longer do this. Do that be more like, you know
So definitely support that okay
Can I drill it in your head anymore to support them or?
Then you like hypnotize you
Oh, my picture's on twerp right, okay, I'll get that. I'll update it
Oh, no the
A veal or house would be awesome, actually
And no the girls are like some of them are like still living with family or
And so they can't really be like oh like, you know all the time so
Yeah
We obey we support the girls, but you kindly support the girl. So yeah, um
That is why
um, so
Azura's up first for donathan rewards to kind of give you an idea and
I'm opening to you know farting about and being open to like kind of the stuff you guys would like to see
Perfectly fine with me no problem
Um
Are the audios on patreon already done do you mean like edit?
Only one month
It's been done. So like june is done
So the girls responsibilities like contract wise is three streams a week if health permitted. Oh my god
If health permitted I got asked by one of the girls
I'll just Azura was like, do I need to give you a doctor's note if I'm sick? I'm like, no
Go rest
My goodness, if you're not well, you're not well
um
So if they're in good health, they are to stream a minimum of three times a week and monthly four audios
I definitely do not want to overwork anyone. I do not want them to feel stressed
I want them to have good times good vibes
happy ending
Yeah
And they've been like super
Patient and like the behind the scenes stuff going on
Do you talk often with one each other? Yeah, we're in a we're in a discord. We talk every day
For two months we've like literally talked every day. Um
You know some
Some girls like might feel like awkward around each other
We had like a couple of gaming sessions leading up to it. We had mock streams together
I like wholeheartedly feel 100 comfortable around these girls. Um
Like when it comes to collabing with other vtubers outside the agency, unfortunately
For me personally, I'm quite inappropriate and
If I don't know the person and I don't know their comfort level. I'm not really interested in like
Asking for like, oh, you want to do a vtuber club type thing? Um
So, uh, I'm probably not going to do too many clubs out with the agency unless like the girls vouch for me
Or something like I'm I'm happy to make friends with their friends
But um, it's probably going to be solo content majority on this channel
And such like content featuring the reeflings when we play our multiplayer games
um
Yeah, I
Um, there is a
Notification discord if you go on the other's twitter. It's notification only the talents are not inside it
the talents
Sorry, my voice is like proper feeling it right now
um
Yeah, management don't have access. Sorry contractors don't have access to the talent
Talents aren't in the notification discord. There's no way you can groom us. We groom you
Why am I freaking frog blinking?
It's me has probably not set up my parameters
One thing get more stable with the group discord for watchers to be joined on the table
What are you saying? I don't have no idea what you just said to me
Will you hang out say together outside of the collapse? I don't even know if we're gonna have time
Like collabs are probably just going to be us meman and like catching up unironically. Um,
Amy's very pumped for
Minecraft server in july is when that comes out my uh group minecraft server
and
I the last time I really properly prolified minecraft
And this is going to set a few views back. Um
The last update was the plant pots were released and I think witches were released and I like never even play that
properly beyond that
So that'll be interesting
Um, I don't really understand anything beyond it
um
I think I had to stroke right in that the way I'm stroking right now, baby. Oh stop. Oh my god. Oh
That's for later, okay
I'm gonna look in this direction because I think maybe my
arm doesn't bend that way
um
Yeah, Amy's like really excited for me. I don't really know what you're supposed to do in the minecraft game
Yeah, because according to the cycle video. Oh wait, should I be on?
Uh chats on the wrong side if I'm looking this way
Fang on this ring. Maybe a lord friendly
Oh, sorry, I actually didn't mean that for once. Sorry
Hold on. I'm looking chat. Excuse me. Oh my hair's in the way. Right. Well, let me put chat
I'm looking here
What are you gonna do about it?
Actually, I'm burping all over you too
Why are you rating my burps?
Oh my god, remember tisker
Remember that time you guys were so nice to me when you could have been so mean to me
She remember that time. Yeah, I remember that time. Ah, my ears are caught my ears. Those aren't my ears
I'm a boogies cut off now. There we go. Fix it
Shebe is having her burps rated too. Yeah, she be burps like me. Oh my god. She's like so oh my god. She's just like me for real for real
Mom, how am I supposed to support that other girls when you keep filling me in?
Maybe you're just a reform. I don't know sometimes like
You don't pick the wait, you don't pick the oh she the oh she picks you
Because it's like you never you don't know like you you can give so many v-tubers a try
And then it's just like one you latch on to and you can't get away from them
Where the things they're not hard for seashells
Isn't it obvious they're seashells like they're transpiring you can see my little hair through them as well if you like look really hard
Why am I not feels hold on a minute got talk this girl
Oh, but I'm still cut off. Stop. I'm not being bullied. I'm being bullied by the youtube studio right now. You know what?
I'm a victim
Kind of can you like kind of see the back of my hair through the sea like it's transpired their shells
They're pearlescent shells in my hair. I still have bunches behind it. Like I have I have hair bubbles
Oh
Yeah
Well, I'll put you behind me
It's very uncomfortable. I know some people are like, uh, I find it hard looking uh, uh, whammy in the eyes and I was like, don't be fit
It's fine. It's fine
Don't mind me
Don't mind me, baby. Oh my god. I love this model. Look at the
I love when models do that neck thing where they only like disappears
It's like the best part like when there is like so much that goes into like picking a model and stuff
I don't like vtuber models where like the art like the hair and the art like is a billion different splits and stuff
Like I don't like that. I like that big chunky hair. I think it looks so
um
and like
I like my pupils as well. Yeah, my little squiddles
any squiddlers
I'll squiddle you in a minute
Who's my oh shit at the moment?
That's actually hard to say
um
The thing is I've probably not got one right now. I watched like 300 people during those applications
There's a lot of people I could oh shit
Um
I'm thinking
You've made me use my brain shame on you. Um
at the moment
I'm biased to fen
um
I just think she's cute and I really like her minds
So fen, fen's got my oh she bolt right now
A scoreboard for the burps honestly, but well
I won't make you use your brain again down straight you won't
Bait or not you better not
Uh, so did you get applications from other vtubers that you were surprised?
Yeah, there was like pre pre established people and I'm like, what do you want?
What what why would you want to join you've already got like an entire brand?
And like thing going on there's literally nothing wrong like they already got their own vtuber models though
Oh my god, my tongue has physics
Nari made sure my tongue wiggles are you ready?
Hey
Go wiggle physics
I
Hey, I'll I'll do a proper hypnosis layer, but my voice is
Uh, I can only emmy can okay
So all the models got the same emotions
But everyone had like a custom toggle or thing going on for them and mine was
As I move the phone out the way mine was
I can like layer the eyes together as well
We'll be playing
I want to suck your
Yeah, I mean go hypnosis and I can layer the eyes if I want to
Do
Right, let me take that stuff off
I'll make my sleep bubble my anime sleep bubble. What do you think? Everyone's got a little idle thing like that super idle
Um, why am I asleep? I'm the phone phone you're
You're trolling I'm getting trolled oh my god
Right right enough enough. I'm ending stream soon. Is she be still streaming?
Be honest
Oh my god, this is a nightmare like absolutely fanny and a boot on this desk right now there we go
She be still streaming. She's not going offline is she?
I
But yeah, I have like one default
That's just for like if you're really susceptible
And then I have my hair as well to really get you going
Like it literally can layer like if you can or if that's like better
So those are my custom things and I can take off my yukata, but I don't even know what button does that
I'm only going to do it for like a water ASMR stream
um
I don't even know
No
Hold on
Yeah, what layer was it that took is it p?
I what layer was it?
What layer was it come on me take my clothes off of me?
What what layer was it?
Nari what one did you set up to I'm just like hitting all the buttons right now just so you should know that
Hey must be the money I'm wearing clothes
man
That part comes later, okay that part comes later
It's uh, bring it back bring it back. Hey bring it back. Hey. Hey. What are you talking about? What are you talking about?
Right, I am gonna make doubly quadruply quadruple check your mouth and that I am reading into sheet
It's just
Oh, did you guys like my meme? I'm just a meme
Who means their life?
Oh
Okay
Uh, we'll be playing video games tomorrow. I'm playing assassin queen. This is my
Oh
This is my game that I'm playing. These are my childhood games
So assassin cute ball of hooch is my favorite game of all time
Uh, James Cameron's average heart is another childhood game. Oh, it's called rinscape is another childhood game
Um, yeah, that's for the first week. So after the stream ends
I'm going to very slowly start putting up the waiting rooms for those ones and then we're gonna get back into it
Everybody get to
I'm starting to lose it. By the way, just so you know, just so you know, uh, right
I am going to read into the ever ever benefits and
uh sheepsters
and
and you guys
Say hi to her and so
Uh, Azura comes on and t-minus two hours
Mercy comes on and wait wait. Let me come on
Let me come on now
Wait a minute this little hooligan coming on
Oh, okay. Okay. Hold on. Hold on. Come on. Come on. Sorry. I was looking at youtube. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I was looking at youtube
I'm sorry. I'm sorry
Oh goodness sake. I need to unbind that like right now
Okay, I take it back. Sheevee you're getting rolled. Uh, we're reading into
emmy because
I rated into sheevee in the last stream
I can't believe I did that again
Thank god it didn't happen on debut by the way. Oh my god. Could you imagine?
I wouldn't be like
Oh, you said that on purpose. Oh, that was so obviously bait
Because I know some v-tubers like do do it as bait, but like I'm actually that freaking daft that I've forgotten to unbind
Sorry
I have apologize. That was pretty scandalous. Okay. You got me for like 10 more minutes until
emmy comes on. Let me refresh marshmallow. You got 10 minutes
Come on boy
You're too autistic to do it willingly literally I can't plan ahead. I'm the last mark
Hey, we will now know the Hulk key is either emmy beezer
Uh, she keeps fishing with bait
Oh, I should go back to the chatting so you guys can see yourself
10 minutes fly by what about infinite time? True
Um, I'm like, um, can I leak my like other stream plans for the rest of the week for the month?
And I'm like, I'm trying to remember what games I've put down
And I've already forgotten them all but they're good games
So we're gonna do old-school runescape consistently for a little bit because I want to get 99 fishing
Uh, no, not fishing wrong one 99 cooking because I'm a whammin
Do do do do do do do do do do do do
And that's actually real
true
um
So I'm gonna try my best horror games. I have a bad heart
I don't do pause my heart is fine. I got it checked
I have to go in if there's any issues. Um
I I can play horror games. It's just ill advised. I would probably do it as like a
a reward
without giving the game away oh I know a game I'm playing next week are you guys
ready I'm playing Skyrim full achievements next week because I know
how to get full achievements in that game because I've done it a few times
before and obviously Skyrim belongs to the North thank you very much I'll be
Stormcloaks yep don't care what they say you know I'm all for Talos
praise be to Talos so that's my duration game for next week is Skyrim
first I believe it takes me just over 24 hours to do full achievements and we
kind of you kind of cheat at the start because you do if you do the
companion's quest line first and then go back to the save before it so you're
not a werewolf and then do the vampire quest the problem I don't know if it's
gonna be a problem if I use an Xbox pass for it because because my Xbox would
break so many times trying to play Skyrim because the save file issues and I
if it's gonna be the same way then there's a strategical way to get full
achievements via the Xbox I already know how to do it I've done it a few times so
don't worry I'll lay it all out for you baby I'll show you how to get full
achievements in Skyrim and under 24 hours that'll be my challenge in under 24
hours I'm sure you can do it under way less but I don't know the strats I'm not
a speedrunner
yes I had a girl ghost me because I told her you picked stormcloth what why
would anyone pick the legion sorry but the elves can perish you're no coming
into my home country being like no you're not allowed to praise Talos
excuse me you can get a little bit of casual fantasy or racism don't mind me
absolutely I'm stormcloth all the way don't care don't care don't care I know
I'm right
being team instinct and Pokemon go because if you always follow your
instincts you'll get there in the end and ironically I'm team instinct oops I
don't know what you guys are in Pokemon go but I'm team instinct and then the
mom was like if you always if you follow your instincts you'll always win
because it doesn't mean you have to win or lose just follow how you feel and
life is good because team mystic is for like wise people and then team red I
forgotten their name is like for for like like I must win people I'm like now
I'm just here for the journey I'm just here for the good time thank you
whoa instinct was the only one that seemed to lack a stick up their bum
excuse me where are we placing sticks team ball of valor oh my god be a lure
and Pokemon go collab let's go wait did I read it wrong if I read it wrong
will there be any dead by daylight streams oh possibly I've not played in
eons I have no idea what the perks are and the news killers are and all that
jazz but it would be oh wait oh there's six of us I don't want anyone to feel
left out if we do like a big six man collab maybe not maybe someone can just
bite it and then we all go run around killing each other and dead by daylight
me come running me chasing the girls listening to them scream whilst I'm
like chainsawing black ops to did they fix the servers and black ops oh we
might be playing black ops 6 I think black ops 6 is coming out the girls said
they would be willing to play it as her was like yeah play black ops before I'm
like oh and then she'd be like yeah give it a go black ops you play black ops
with me I'm pretty sure there's like a black ops 6 isn't all or is a black ops
5 I'm not much of a horror fan I'm very boring I don't watch much media and if I
do watch media I like fantasy like Game of Thrones or Lord of the Rings or the
Hobbit I really like the old no technology type stuff I like the community
stuff guys we still do not have the Shire Lego set all I'm saying is when the
Shire Lego set finally comes out we've got the freaking tower no one wants the
tower no one wants the freaking elven place either like wouldn't just give me
either bag end that yeah give me the full of bag end or like give me the
full of the Shire I don't care how much money it is I'll let you spend thousands
I don't care like Lego get your shoes together there's a new Lord of the
Rings game coming out as well and and it's like where are workshops you're
sitting on a gold mine why does no one want anything of the Shire the Shire
just like feels like community and everyone's got flowers and everyone's got
a little job and they all go down to the wee pub and is it dragon or some pub
dragon not all the names are with me right now and but like why why are you
not investing in the Shire people want the Shire I demand the Shire
I don't want the tower I don't want the black gate I don't want any of that stuff
if it comes over building on street 100% no question us the new wetter game the
game art looks curious to say the least it looks curious have I ever eaten
haggis yes I'm Scott's I've had haggis um actually well I tell you a little
secret for future content St Andrews Day is like National Scottish Day and it's
in November and I'm going to be hosting a game show for my gen mates because
thank god none of them are British and or else they'd be cheating in my game
show but I'm gonna do a Scottish game show but that's the secret for you and
me baby okay keep it secret I need to kiss you to keep it secret
yeah yeah but yes I'm doing a Scottish game show I'm gonna make them spell
Scottish words I'm gonna make them guess Scottish memes I'm gonna make them do a
few things our Jaffa cakes cookies biscuit or a cake oh my god
I'd say they're a cake honestly what's the best meal deal honestly though I'm
wondering if I could get iron brew sent to their houses to all try at the same
time oh that would actually be kind of banging though not gonna lie be like
right everyone open your can of iron brew tell me if it tastes like ginger and
bubblegum oh what's it what's the go-to Greg's sauce a Greg's order I'm brewing
buck fast oh could I give them buck fat no I can't give them alcohol man yeah
because I mean it can be a little strong he gave us alcohol Greg's tier list oh
cheese and hamburger get sorry but she's in hand but if they don't put too much
butter on the cheese and hamburger then I and the best pie not pie pastry beans
cheese and sausage I'm like 90% sure my dad was at all he used to go get it for
me so I am it's like I moved out and and I like I don't drive and I didn't have
access to a bake like I cycle kind of why I got a big ass but and oh is it me alive
oh have I missed me I might have to wrap up I think it means live I'm so sorry
I'm gonna have to wrap up and what I had I heard I wrap up actually no don't wrap
up and Pregnation please who said that let me just like quadruple check I'm
okay yeah okay okay we did it we did it it was unprofessional two point oh
let's go baby let's go right I'm gonna go rest my voice for tomorrow's
absolute chaos shortly you will see my streams for the week appear I don't know
if we're doing free chat I don't know some people do free chat I just kind of
talk in the free chat like the stream I'm doing next okay thank you so much my
nothing but pleasure holy fuck I will make up for a lost time I promise you I
will make up for so much lost time let me kick and kick I did hopefully hopefully
you like the girls but thank you so so much I will stream to use tomorrow and
yep your hero thank you so much for waiting on me and thank you for coming
out of cryo freeze has been a number pleasure number pleasure I love you so
much I will talk to you so soon eight hours tomorrow be there be square don't
worry if you actually can't be there for the full time I'm just teasing you I'm
teasing you on that little non-existent tentacles talk to you later okay see
tomorrow bye bye